la 75e édition du festival de cannes
démarre aujourd'hui pendant deux
semaines radio sensations vous proposera
de rencontrer les franciliens qui font
vivre le cinéma qu'ils soient
exploitants acteurs réalisateurs ou
producteurs la région ile de france
justement poursuit son soutien à
l'industrie du cinéma avec un budget
annuel de près de 25 millions d'euros
elle accompagne chaque année environ 150
films 21 d'entre eux seront mises à
l'honneur cette année au festival de
cannes parmi eux le film coupé de michel
hazanavicius la région ile de france l'a
soutenu à hauteur de 360 2000 euros au
titre du fonds de soutien il sera
projeté ce soir dès la cérémonie
d'ouverture
laurent il vient akira muriel 10,1
hatsumi et anaïs elle devient chine à
sous et moi je suis kent par contre ils
veulent pas non et j'te jure te marres
pas ce match je suis allé grand mec tu
m'étonnes que je fixe et mobile tu viens
de ta gueule tu me fais chier depuis le
début des répétitions
sacamerd
saloperie dont on dit oui
[Musique]